why are you backing him i'm backing
rishi tonight because he has been tested
in the heat of a crisis he was the
person that led our financial response
to covid and he's the person i think can
take us through the situation that we're
facing as a country right now
reuniting the country recovering the
economy and leading this country uh
forward and that's why i think he's the
best person to be the conservative party
leader and the prime minister of the
united kingdom we're heading into a
recession and he left us to it
left us too i mean he has taken action
to support the worst off in this country
i mean his raising the threshold he
resigned i think he resigned the actions
that he saw as being indefensible in
downing street and now he's taking and
the action that he took as chancellor in
terms of raising the threshold for
national insurance saving the average
person in this country 330 pounds taking
150 pounds off of over 10 million
people's council tax i think that's
shown by his actions that he can take
the action necessary to support the
british people through what's going to
be a very difficult period and now in
his plan to become leader he's going to
take action to get inflation under
control grow the economy and then cut
taxes and i think that's what we need to
hear what's he going to do to try and
win over scott's photos though because
traditionally tourists don't do very
well north of the border well i'm living
testament to the fact that conservatives
can get elected the joke is that there
are more uh flipping pandas in scotland
than there are tory mps we've got three
times as many uh
uh that we do pandas in scotland i got
elected and i'd like to in 2017 we've
got 13 conservatives elected in scotland
in 2017. yeah we fell back in 2019 but
we are far and away better in a better
place than we were at any stage between
1997 and 2017. and i think that we can
go on and grow that and i think rishi
seneca is just the man to appeal to
scots not just scots appeals people all
around the united kingdom in terms of
pragmatic sensible approach to
government as as he has demonstrated
already as chancellor of the exchequer
um he's surrounded by a bunch of
candidates who want to cut tax he
doesn't want to do that yet what makes
him think that people will vote for him
i think people will look at his
pragmatic and sensible plans plans by
the way which have been endorsed by
norman lamont plans that this morning
have been endorsed by william hague who
says that margaret thatcher would be
looking very skeptically is some of the
plans unveiled by other candidates one
of the players
no he wasn't prime minister but he was
referring to margaret thatcher and his
view was that she would be looking very
suspiciously at some of these plans to
cut tax one plan yesterday that would
take two percent uh out of uh gdp out of
the economy uh with no plan uh of how to
replace that i think it would be utterly
irresponsible to borrow on the back of
another a new generation to cover what
uh some of these people are planning to
do now and that's why rishi sarah's got
this pragmatic and sensible plan to get
inflation under control to grow the
economy and then yes to cut taxes all
conservatives want to see lower taxes
it's just a matter of
tourists want to see low taxes i know
everybody in the country wants to see
lower taxes but only conservatives
actually ever deliver lower taxes and i
believe that rishi sinha has got the
plan to see this through taxation um
it's in 70 years so that's not
necessarily true
but if you look at what he's done for
the worst off in this country you know
150 pound off of council tax you know
the national threshold rise taking 330
pounds uh off of the uh giving 330
pounds back to the average worker in
this country i think he's demonstrated
by his actions that he is a tax cutting
chancellor he will be a tax cutting
prime minister but we need to take
sensible and pragmatic steps to get
there it'd be utterly unconservative to
pass off to a new generation just
because we want to cut taxes just now i
think that we need to get the economy
under control get inflation under
control and then we can be in a place to
cut taxes so the others are being
irresponsible i wouldn't say they're
being responsible where are they well
look
we're blessed in the conservative party
with a huge you know a depth of talent
and we've seen
all of these candidates come forward and
put forward their plans and they're
entitled to do so but i believe that
rishi sunak's plan is the only sensible
plan the only realistic plan because
ultimately we've got to get inflation
under control first before we can move
down the route of cutting tax and i
think the british people understand that
okay an ally of pretty patel has
admitted to sending a dirty dossier
calling rishi a liar who can't be
trusted on tax
uh look
i'm not going to get drawn into
anything it's not very nice so is it
well no it's not very nice but i mean
i'm not getting drawn into any of this
sort of blue on blue attack i think that
at the end of the day we're going to
have to unite behind whoever is elected
uh leader of the conservative party and
as i said we're blessed that we have a
broad range of talent within the
conservative party a plethora of people
standing to be leader all of whom might
be proud
to serve under as prime minister and i
don't think it behooves anybody in this
party to be engaging in that sort of uh
that sort of attack on another how can
he be trusted though when he uh
contributed to the downfall of the prime
minister
i think he can i think you have to look
at his his actions in government the way
that he led us through covert you know
saving 11 million jobs in this country
through the furlough scheme 740 000 jobs
by the way uh in scotland and i think if
you look at his record in government
look at what he's doing on the cost of
living situation looking at his plans
which he'll unveil in greater detail
later today to get inflation under
control to grow the economy and to
reunite the country then i think that he
has what it takes to be the leader and
prime minister of this country it was a
very very slick campaign video yeah how
long did it take to film it
i mean look he was able to develop the
furlough scheme within a matter of days
at the in the heat of the the battle
against covert he's able to produce a
video i'm sure within the same period of
time when did he start filming it i mean
that's a question you'd have to ask him
but there's the as i said he's been able
to it's it's a good video um but he
approached you
look i i i've known rishi for for years
since i first came into the house of
commons i've been talking to all the
candidates i know them all uh pretty
well so would he approach you to be
involved with his campaign i didn't
speak to russia sudac about his
leadership ambitions until after he
resigned as chancellor of these chequers
okay so what do you say to people who
are suggesting that he's been
campaigning behind the scenes for many
months well i mean that's that that's
you know a matter of opinion he as i
said he only spoke to me
i've got no evidence that that is the
truth so he only spoke to me about his
leadership ambitions after he resigned
his chances
i mean failed to prepare prepares to
fail this there's absolutely nothing
wrong with it and i think that the uh
the the outgoing prime minister uh was
planning to become prime minister long
before he left office as foreign
secretary so there's absolutely nothing
wrong with planning to become prime
minister i dare say there are people in
the house of commons who are looking at
in the in the far the
in the in the future their ambitions in
terms of becoming leader of this this
particular thing that had been planning
for a while
i look that's that's that's for rishi to
answer the question as i said he never
spoke to me
well he never spoke to me about his
leadership ambitions until after he
resigned are you sure yes